well welcome back to Washington so just
who are the candidates in the
presidential election both have lived
much of their lives in the public eye
but yet mystery swirl around them in
just a moment we'll hear from the author
of Trump nation a biography naturally of
Donald Trump but first son joined by the
journalist and author Suzanne Goldberg
author of Madam President to find out
more about candidate Hillary Clinton
very good to see you Suzanne Madam
President is that you making the title
is that you making an assumption well
there was a question mark at the end of
the titles yes so I think that is a
question is America ready to to elect a
woman to be President
I originally wrote that book in 2008 but
eight years later it's just as much a
big question so yeah I mean you've
looked into the background and this is
both I suppose the advantage in the
impediment for Hillary Clinton isn't it
the length of time she's witnessed and
been in public service right back to
Arkansas Bill Clinton as governor then
president then she's a senator then
Secretary of State well clearly she's
prepared but people just go as Donald
Trump says you're an insider that is
true and she is really caught in this
predicament and it's a predicament
that's about gender on the one hand you
know she has to show that she has the
experience to be President to overcome
this idea that women are too
soft-hearted too flighty that somehow
can't deal with the wiggers of office
but on the other hand that long resume
comes with baggage and baggage from the
scandals of the Clinton White House when
her husband Bill Clinton was president
and from what has been her own record as
Secretary of State just talk about how
tricky that was for her during the the
Bill Clinton years in the White House
and those scandals the the kind of
standing by your man approach that she
took absolutely at that time you know
Hillary Clinton sort of saved her
husband's presidency by standing by her
man but the way she did it actually hurt
her own image because she actually
quoted Tammy Wynette and she said I'm
not standing by my man like some old
country-western song I'm doing it
because I honor what he's done and so
she annoyed a lot of people she
triggered she hit some nerve with a lot
of people
and that in some ways is the beginning
of you know this whole idea of Hillary
Clinton as a polarizing figure for some
women she's inspirational for other
women and men she's too much to take but
then you looked into that first turn 92
to 96 when she did want to get involved
I mean you had considerable intellect
get involved as first lady and be more
than just the decorative first lady and
she got slapped back for that she got a
huge amount of criticism she did and I
would argue that there was a lot going
on there for one that was there they
were these perceptions about what a
first lady should do should it be an
entirely ceremonial role should it be
you know she wanted to drive directly
into policy she wanted to beat White
House chief of staff at first then she
settled for having this big lift of the
health care policy there was a backlash
against that but I think you also have
to acknowledge that the way Hillary
Clinton conducted that exercise was
flawed from the beginning she made a lot
of mistakes why do you think I mean
right fast forward up to now why do you
think she hasn't been able to get any of
that that magic that in a different way
of course that President Obama then
candidate Obama was able to do in 2008 I
remember being here being in Boston
where he's from and people who weren't
Democrats saying we want to vote for
this guy imagine imagine the United
States has its first african-american
president well now it's on the cusp it
could have its first female president
but this none of that buzz going round
there's none of that buzz and you have
to acknowledge also that Barack Obama is
an incredibly gifted politician and
public speaker and when he comes to the
stage time after time it's just it's
just magical many times Hillary Clinton
is is much more prosaic campaigner so
there's that as well and there is that
long record that we've just talked about
and there is in belt resistance to the
idea of women rising to that highest
office but I mean amongst women in
particular does any of that the idea
that she may be about to break through
the glass ceiling does that resonate as
a connector that's huge if you look at
the numbers you know she has in some
parts of the population a 20-point lead
about Donald Trump and he in a way has
play
into that because of who he is and he's
you know it's very stark now what the
choice is in terms of women and you know
the role of women in society you know
got Donald Trump who's sort of made
constant derogatory remarks about women
and has sort of joked about sexual
assault of women you've got some of his
surrogates now on the campaign trail
making dismissive comments about women
and then you have Hillary Clinton who
stands for women's advancement and I
have seen through the polling numbers a
lot of women responding to that message
they're really fed up with what the kind
of remarks that Trump has been making I
want you to take Suzanne on there on the
whole email scandal I mean well you know
what's your belief on what went wrong is
it just that she she didn't get it she
didn't understand it it's really not a
spy or anything like I don't have to do
this this is Hillary Clinton's bad side
which is Hillary Clinton is a paranoid
control freak she really thought that
she did not have to allow the public to
look at her email that was the only
reason to put the server in the basement
she did not want Freedom of Information
requests from journalists she did not
want biographers to be looking at all of
that email it's not that she used a
State Department email for government
business and the private for private she
wanted all of her email off the books
well great talking to you Suzanne thank
you very much indeed we have a bit of
insight into Hillary Clinton Suzanne
Goldberg there